Your applications and data are spread across multiple public, private and edge clouds.
And your users are everywhere.
How do you keep everything connected, secure and working?
If you're struggling, you're not alone.
There's so many skills to master, it's understandable that many IT professionals are worried they're not doing a good job.
Yeah, I get it.
Sometimes it's the tools.
Other times it's technology.
And it can even be how your organization is-- or isn't --aligned.
But no matter the cause,
the result is apps that don't deliver the value your business needs and users that don't like the experience.
So how do you get it right?
Let's go through three things you can do to help your team succeed and improve app connectivity,
namely: collaborate, simplify, and automate.
Let me explain how improving these factors can help.
Let's start with collaborate.
That's the key to synergy between your devOps and cloudOps teams.
Your devOps team is focused on deploying applications.
On the other hand, your cloudOps team is responsible for application connectivity.
You need to remove the silos between devOps and cloudOps and help them collaborate.
Of course, your team has different roles and different performance metrics, but everyone has one common goal:
making sure applications can run smoothly and securely.
So instead of separate teams using separate tools, they need one solution to collaborate.
A shared experience, like a common dashboard, can make a huge difference.
Next up, simplify.
You need to simplify the connectivity of sites and users to your apps that are deployed on any and all clouds.
Let's say you have a new business application and it must be deployed in multiple cloud locations as well as on prem.
Having a solution that lets you deliver simple, secure and predictable application-centric connectivity is critical.
Okay, the final factor is to automate monitoring.
You need to see at a glance how your apps and infrastructure components are connected.
You especially know what's slow, or even worse, what's broken.
With that heads up, you can then use AI to fix the problem.
For example, using AI to automatically make connectivity changes or reprovision transient applications based on policy.
Let's face it, it's no surprise to say we live in a highly distributed world
and cloud technology plays an increasingly important role in it.
That's why you can't afford any roadblocks to multi-cloud adoption like siloed teams or problems with app connectivity.
So if you're looking for ways to help everyone succeed, we recommend looking for solutions
that give you the application-centric connectivity that works in edge, hybrid and multi-cloud environments.
And most importantly, that bridges the unnecessary silos between devOps and cloudOps.
To learn more, check out the links below.